these flasks are filled with different
species of seaweed
all unique to australia pier windberg
has been studying how to unlock their
potential as new
superfoods with proven benefits not only
for the environment
but also the body we're inventing it as
we go
because it's new to australia the
systems
um the foods and then teaching people
that
just eat pasta with seaweed in it and
and that will benefit you
and it benefits the environment
she's opened australia's first factory
making food grade products from a
domestic species of green seaweed
carbon dioxide is captured from a nearby
wheat refinery
to help the seaweed grow it's then
processed to make health products and
food
like muesli and pasta many of our
chronic lifestyle disorders like
diabetes
mineral deficiencies inflammatory
disorders
could be addressed by adding seaweed
back into the diet
it could also help with wound healing
seaweed extracts from the farm are being
used to print human tissue with 3d
technology
with the hope of eventually creating
artificial skin
we've just opened the lip and there's a
whole treasure
trove of possibilities that we can
exploit that this is a new industry
this is the beginnings of a new industry
in australia
seaweed has been used around the world
for centuries but as an industry in
australia
it's largely untapped now researchers
are looking at everything from feeding
cattle seaweed to reduce emissions to
making plastics
of course all plants absorb carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere but the
difference with seaweed is just how
efficient it is
it grows much faster than trees doesn't
need fertilizer or fresh water
and at the same time has a long life
span
[Music]
making it an appealing option to
permanently capture carbon on a
significant scale
to tackle climate change putting a price
on carbon would really help a lot of the
industries that are kind of starting to
emerge that are trying
to increase how much carbon we capture
out of the atmosphere
but pricing carbon is a contentious
issue in australia
where coal mines are still being
expanded
pier windberg believes seaweed holds the
answers to many
of the world's climate challenges nicola
gage aljazeera
south coast new south wales